i saw a great quote actually by gary
kasparov where he said the eternal
paradox of peak performance is
learning while still carrying on as if
you appear invincible oh and
it was i thought it was quite nice yeah
that's exactly what jana ponnichi has to
do he has to learn from this
this last few games and then just carry
on
get to
get to game 10 with a smile on his face
and uh this belief that yes he can do it
and that will be an accomplishment right
yeah mentally we talked about the 1984
match karpov against casper and that's
one to draw inspiration from so
yeah definitely he should be listening
to the words of garry kasparov
wow
game nine is over a terrible blunder by
anna pomnyacci will they talk about it
apparently they will
yeah but i thought maybe i could connect
e7
no i mean okay for a moment i just
thought this is like some huge advantage
but actually should be fine
yeah i mean i mean i've already seen
this before this one
maybe it's how i thought it's like
slightly better i mean
even more slightly but yeah somehow
yeah if there's a 6k there is just no
way i mean no it's just
being awesome because the phone only 46
is never an idea because of 165 yeah
it's funny
[Music]